check this out I have a piece of PVC
electrical conduit and on one end I've
labeled an O and the other end I've
labeled an X now I'm going to put it on
the table and press down with my
forefinger on the oh and I'm gonna give
it a spin do you see that you can only
see the O as it spins around let's make
sure that's not just a fluke I'll try it
again so putting my finger on the oh and
I see only OHS well let's try putting my
finger on the X and see what we see then
and we see only X's so why is that why
do you only see the label of the side
that you press Y don't want to tell you
the answer right away you could google
it but I don't think that would be very
satisfying so I think the best way would
be to go down to your local hardware
shop pick up a bit of a electrical
conduit and cut it into various links
now to help you out I have made a
shorter length of tubing with the same
markings on it so let's give that one a
try and see how it compares so first
I'll press on the o we see three eyes
when I do it like that
what you don't see the X's yeah but if
you put your finger on the X to start
with you see three X's so what's the
deal if you like send me in a video
response and I'll post it below now if
you're too lazy for any of that I'll
post the answer in a week so you know
subscribe and you'll find out why this
happens
so normally when I'm filming my videos I
have to approach people and ask them to
talk to me about physics but while I was
filming the spinning tube trick a few
kids came up to me and wanted to see
what I was doing and we got to
discussing how the trick works and one
of the kids suggested that I try
spinning the tube on a glass table now a
glass table is beyond the budget of
veritasium but a piece of glass resting
precariously on the backs of two chairs
that I think I can manage but if this
was glass and you flicked on the X on we
were looking from below you'd see I
reckon you'd still see the X's I
tricking you so I don't know I mean now
instead of saving this for another
episode I thought I would do it right
now and that way you may have a little
bit more evidence to figure out how the
trick is working so I'm gonna place the
tube on the glass surface and I'm going
to press down on the X and I want you to
make a prediction if we look from the
underside from underneath the glass what
will we see will we see an O like the
student thought we see an X like I said
we would we see both the X and the O or
will we see neither so I want you to
make a prediction now click on one of
the annotations if you're watching on
YouTube if you're watching on a mobile
device I'll put the link in the
description so hopefully you can check
that out let's give it a shot
so make a prediction now three two one